prépare toi ce qui va arriver jackson
storm appartient à la nouvelle
génération de coureurs high tech un
nouveau venu impressionnant jackson
store jackson store jackson storm est
unique en son genre salut champion
vous avez un beau palmarès
vous n'imaginez pas à quel point je suis
content de vous éliminer
excusez moi j'ai pas bien compris
m'éliminer vous avez très bien compris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu ne seras plus jamais le cours a plus
tu as été
on ne peut pas remonter le temps petit
mais on peut remettre les pendules à
l'heure le manque de la compétition
automobile est en train de changer
tapis de course soufflerie réalité
virtuelle nos équipes travaillent et
simulateurs de course interactif vous
voulez vous on a un peu de boulot je
suis trop contente de pouvoir rentrer en
train de battre secours
m
[Musique]
la plage bas valais chaque semaine des
vétérans renoncer à la compétition pour
céder la place à de jeunes coureurs plus
rapide
vous envisagez de prendre votre retraite
oui je parle des photos mails 6 4 ne
sera jamais plus rapide que storm
mais tu peux être plus malin que lui
bonne chance dit vont en avoir besoin
c'est moi qui déciderai quand je veux
leur arrivée
ne gagnera pas
je vais m'occuper de toi storm
[Applaudissements]